okay so you can't be spontaneous before
you can read the body
got it that's that's it only appears
possible
when everyone restricts themselves to
forms
but somebody who's truly spontaneous can
tell you're forcing forms
or you're taking advantage of the
restrictions okay
so uh this is he's gonna work on
on knowing where the sweet spot is on my
face
oh he hits me in a stop hit fashion
okay uh my job is
i'm gonna practice the reading of what
he's doing so
he has a sweet stop hit on the jab um
or you can do the sweet spot stop hit on
the cross
okay and then my side is i'm reading his
body
but if i'm going like this let's say he
does that same one again
no that that's taking advantage of the
drone okay
i i i have like a game this is how fast
the conveyor belt is moving
and i don't get to hesitate okay
okay let's go okay so we're continuing
that girl he's trying to get this sweet
spot while i'm timing
what i mean by sweet spot if he throws
it out here he'll tuck he'll touch me
but
it's not going to stop my my uh forward
progress it's not going to interrupt me
okay
or if i get here yeah he'll hit me but
his kid is not going to do the same
thing
okay it's like is he is he's just let go
of the boxing
as he walks at me just walk at me please
he's just walking boom i want to hit him
in that
in that mid kind of step so every time
he comes in
boom okay so same thing here there's a
sweet spot when he
catches it boom that's what he wants to
practice okay
so he's doing that drill i'm doing my
drill
he's doing his drill you can do whatever
you want okay
and you're gonna end up on one of these
corners all right
now you're gonna feel his pressure
trying to come back like he's gonna get
a
there he okay
so you'll feel his pressure comes back i
want you to come up
just like you're re-racking the back
squat or the shoulder press okay
or your back squat so we'll do that one
again
boom i'll feel him i'll move up bring my
center
we'll go on the cross boom there it is
right there
you'll feel it pull up
[Music]
it's not enough to go forward bring your
center
[Music]
okay try okay so i'm working to stop
it he goes boom
now
come on
no i have to stay still my drill
okay okay so once i go
home and he goes this fight is rotating
in this aggression you see
and i absorb and
you step around inward confusion of
every single technique you have
okay so i'm going there
so yeah i don't know where your control
points are gonna be if that doesn't
matter in my
home that doesn't matter so maybe i'll
take this rib cage you see
when kaizen knocked it here kaiten
nugget on the leg
maybe this hand is still up in my face
he's going here
you see uh
[Music]
so don't try to pick something it's
what's more important
is the yield
okay so the the point is not
not to contest so i don't contest there
and i'm not contesting here and when you
turn
i'm inside
you got to pay attention to my what my
body's doing so i leave my hands
up
that's that's what makes your hands
irrelevant
[Music]
then you then you'll just find your
control point
but he has when he turns when when he
grabs
he can't feel this he can't feel the
front foot
so i move you see and now he's feeling
the shoulder
he goes and he doesn't feel
[Music]
i'm going
[Applause]
get enough of the front end of the
front inward position
then you hit the leg on the other side
boom legs right here
you're gonna try to pick the leg up drop
the lat then the leg
so inside nothing
okay try it again okay so he's going
and i'm here this this is my
this is my contact point so let's look
at him
you're fine he's got uh
he's starting to get an underhook under
this arm
and then he's got this hook there okay
uh that's what i adhere to
[Music]
so those those aren't the things i've
tried to escape from
the only thing i can't let him get the
headlight that's a lot of did they
conquer so
when he when he's here he's trying to
get the headlock my head
is working in an ik adhesion
okay then his body's doing spinal
displacement so i yield
there is the hole
i'm not here that's not what i'm doing
i'm taking advantage of the same thing
is in my keyhole
so i have to create this boy
don't feel him he doesn't feel me he's
aggressive
and i'm neutral
that's what you should be working on
okay